le 25 juin 1975 jean donatini
s'apprêtaient à partir en vacances
lorsqu'ils accompagnent un commissaire
de la dst chez carlos celui-ci l'abattra
d'une balle en pleine tête
encore maintenant moi je ne peux pas
pardonner des gens disent il faut pas
mois-ci menhirs et je vous dis
honnêtement si avec la peine de mort moi
je voudrais qu'on l'a
quand tu passes qui l'a 38 le monde
c'est pas possible j'ai entendu 83
personnes hier
si c'est pas possible on arrive à des
choses pareilles c'est vraiment à mousse
depuis le 4 rue de limoges à 20 c'est
devenu la maison du souvenir pour sa
famille
jean donain tiny qui aura vécu 25 ans
avant d'entrer dans la police sur les
conseils de son frère ne vont plus tard
ce sera donc le drame de la rue toullier
et depuis près de vingt ans une traque
sans relâche de la moindre information
sur les faits et gestes du terroriste
les médias parfois cité des faits
d'armes de ce triste personnage mais
sachant les protections qui ne jouissait
pas de nouveaux pays qui est que les
terroristes ne tuons pas certain qu'il
serait un jour arrêté à on a toujours
suivi sa trace à chaque fois que l'on
dit carlos ça me glace des pieds à la
tête et j'écoute
alors une fois on nous avait dit qu'il
était qu'ils étaient dans tel pays d'un
pays souvent quand j'entends aussi tôt
que j'en pensais c'est épouvantable
aujourd'hui jean donatini laisse une
place à son nom à reims est une famille
soulagé à l'idée que la justice lui sera
rendue